andrea rayne is here hi good morning how
are you um so um the king is dead long
live the king or queen who are you most
worried about
well i think at the moment the
conservative party have really lost the
trust of the british public they propped
up boris johnson for mums knowing full
well that is marred in sleaze and
scandal so i'm not worried about any of
them actually if you look where me and
keir was when we took over the labour
party and where the labour party was in
the polls we were in a devastating
position we've come forward with a
programme for government which i think
the british people are starting to look
at now and they've seen the shambles of
what the conservative party are so bring
on whoever comes forward because they've
all been marred in the sleeves and the
scandals that boris johnson has brought
to number 10. yeah but they'll still be
in power for two years unless of course
you go for a vote of confidence i was
speaking to seth dave he sat there in
the last hour and he said as early as
monday is that is that your view well we
think that you know boris johnson can't
stay another minute in downing street
he's been proven that he's not fit to
govern and therefore the conservative
party need to elect somebody to lead
their party pretty quickly or get some
interim leader in that is not somebody
who has been disgraced who's lost the
confidence of their own party let alone
the british public and if they don't do
that we're very clear that we will put a
motion of no confidence forward before
the summer recess to ensure that that
exchange happens and that this
conservative party do the right thing by
the british public which they haven't
done quite frankly for the last few
months so what's the time skill um ed
davie says monday
yeah well we obviously will be working
with our whips to make sure that that
happens as soon as quickly as possible
if the conservative party is showing no
signs of doing the right thing by the
british people you know the frustration
is it's time and time again the
opposition i've had to really push to
get what we consider to be the basic
standards that you would expect in
public life you're hesitating because
you know you won't win it no we're not
no i think that we can win it and i
think if we can't win it because
and if we don't win it because of
conservatives prop up the prime minister
i think that they're going to find that
very devastating for them not just for
the next general election but i think
that will keep him out of power for for
a very long time because the british
people have had enough you know they
need to get their house in order if they
don't then we will step forward as we
have done whether that's with our
solutions to the cost of living crisis
we'll step forward again to make sure
that boris johnson doesn't remain in
number 10. but it's all talk though
isn't it for me you can't do anything
about it well we will we'll put the vote
with no confidence forward we're very
clear on that yeah as soon as like i say
we'll speak to the whips and we'll do it
as soon as possible if it shows if it
shows yeah well we haven't got long left
for recess quite frankly so it could be
it could be as early as next week yeah
because you know we haven't got long
left before the summer recess and you
know i've heard conservatives say well
it's recess so i think one of them said
well it's you know it's quieter it's not
quiet we've got the situation in ukraine
we've got a cost of living crisis at the
moment that's engulfing the british
public so we can't continue to have
boris johnson number 10 i mean it's
pretty scary the thought of what he's
going to do i mean the rumors are the
rumors are he wants to stay just so he
can have a party and checkers i mean
it's completely unbelievable that that's
what he wants to do party at checkers if
he wants to it's his grace and favor
home and as long as it doesn't cost the
taxpayer any money who cares he's been
grace and favoring for a very long time
on the back of the taxpayers of this
country i think that what they want to
see is somebody that they can have trust
in that's not going to lie to the
british people and he's not going to act
in their own self doing that now we're
in the process of doing that and he's he
said yeah okay fine the herd has decided
i'm gone um he's he can't he's lame duck
prime minister can't do anything so just
leaving there well that's the problem he
is a lame duck but the problem is is
that he doesn't got the command of his
cabinet and they can't continue to deal
with the issues that our country face
you know we had an edge up until
yesterday we didn't even have any
ministers in the education at a time
when you know we've got the school exams
coming and we've got the situation with
child care costs so in each department i
raised it yesterday in the house around
making sure we can get sign off for
secret service and for some of the
protocols there and the damaging effects
that we have when the government are
paralyzed to to govern the country and
that's what we see under boris johnson
most of the people are even stepping up
have said they've got no confidence in
him so i think it's an untenable
position and it's not fair to to prolong
this drama any longer for the british
public
you might not have a leader yourself by
monday
well i'm confident we will have a leader
by monday both myself and care believe
you're alluding to uh durham and the
investigation sherlock holmes yeah well
um
you know both myself and claire look
here are very clear that we don't
believe that we've broken the rules but
we do believe in the principle that if
you're a lawmaker you can't break the
law and then lead your party into
government that's not acceptable and
we're both confident we haven't look we
know that when we voted for those
restrictions that they were some of the
most restrictive pieces of legislation
that has ever been given to this
generation of british public and we knew
it was for the safety of them so both
myself and kate took that really
seriously and we don't believe we broke
the law i'm very confident i've not lost
a sleepless night over it because i know
that when i couldn't see my
granddaughter i was not doing anything
other than working and doing what i
needed to do to continue to be the
deputy leader of the labour party but
you still stand by the fact that you
will step down if you are 100 yeah 100
because i think it matters this is this
is beyond me it matters to what the
british public think of politicians and
at the moment quite frankly the republic
don't think very highly of us and that's
because of uh circumstances like we've
seen whether that's with uh uh pinscher
what's happened recently whether that's
with boris johnson propping up owen
patterson when the scandal engulfed them
whether that's partying in downing
street all these things have undermined
public trust in politicians and me and
cair have been very clear it's not about
us it's about the role of being a public
servant and i think that principle is
really important so what if the nac say
we won't accept your resignation well
the nec won't do that i mean the nec
would accept it if we and keir said that
you know if we were fined and we can't
go we don't know we still think you're
the best people i mean it's a
hypothetical question
but would you go against the nec if they
said we don't want you to leave the nec
will not do that i know i know our
national executive of the labour party
i've been in the labour party since i
was 20 and 42 now so i've been there a
long time and i know rnac they wouldn't
do that because the thing is with the
labour party it's not about one person
we are a movement about being in
government to change things for ordinary
people in this country to make life
better for them we have in the past
we've done that in government we've got
a proven track record of doing that and
we'll do it again just before i let you
go the standards committee is it is
there any point now in them continuing
to find out whether or not the prime
minister misled parliament i think there
is a point to it because the prime
minister has said he'll step down as
prime minister but of course he'd still
be the mp for his local area and i think
people do think standards matter and you
know i think that investigation is
important so people can get to the true
facts we still haven't had the covert
inquiry as well that's going to be
coming
up and people want to know answers to
what the prime minister's been up to we
had this week the prime minister
admitting that he met with the former
kgb spy
in secret without any of his officials
with him and he hasn't done that before
now that's a national security risk and
people want answers to what he was the
prime minister at the time he was
foreign secretary which is just as bad
you know his foreign secretary and he
shouldn't be doing that he knows he
shouldn't be doing that and yet he's
done it and that was a national security
risk that's why he's not supposed to do
that and he's just completely
disregarded the rules and that's why he
can't carry on because he is a risk to
the country if he lies to the british
public if he doesn't do the right thing
and follow the rules even his own rules
that he put in place then that's not
acceptable if he doesn't hand back the
keys by monday you're going to go for a
photo of no confidence if he doesn't
unback the keys we'll be making sure
that he's turfed out there he cannot
continue we'll do it as quickly as
possible next week next week okay thanks
very much indeed for joining